There is no meaning. There is only lore.
I need to get my notes out. I need to get 'em...
-You staggered back into the house with a certain look about you.
Oh boy, did I ever...
All right, so I just got back from Glass.
-Okay.
-2019!
Glass, the sequel to Split, which was the stealth sequel...
sidequel...
To Unbreakable.
I think I like Unbreakable a little less after seeing this.
-Well, Dan? Was it... okay?
-No, it was not okay.
It was not okay.
So actually, just, while we're talking about Unbreakable,
one of the first things...
So there's a scene kind of in the middle-ish of the movie where
All of a sudden I'm sitting there, thinking, like,
"Wow, Bruce Willis remembered how to act again!"
And it took me a couple more seconds to realize,
"Wait, no, this is literally just a scene from Unbreakable."
-They just reused--
-They just re... yeah. They just reused...
a substantial amount of footage from Unbreakable.
-Curious. Okay.
-Yeah.
So there's there's at least two full sequences
that are just included straight from, straight from it,
and then a bunch of other like small, smaller clips.
Ditto with Splice [sic]. The less of Splice is used...
-Split.
-Split!
-Splice is an entirely different movie!
-Very, very different movie.
It is a very cheap movie.
-Oh. That's too bad.
Like okay, so, Split. So I just saw Split for the first time last night. Hated it.
Awful movie. Now, I do suspect that a little bit
or at least a substantial bit of my, like, dislike of Split
stems a lot from kind of the foreknowledge that
it's like, okay, well, Glass comes out tomorrow
So, if we're gonna talk...
if we wanna talk about Dan's Controversial Spoiler Opinions...
Is it indeed possible for, ah...
I would say that my viewing of Split was indeed ruined
by the spoiler of knowing that it is the prequel to Glass,
rather than the movie ruining itself by revealing that it is in fact the prequel to Glass.
So instead of getting angry after the movie ended,
I got angry as the movie was going.
It's really all that that changed.
It just advanced the anger by, you know, ninety minutes.
So this is a very cheap movie. If you're gonna look at the budget...
Split was actually made for, like, nine million dollars
which in terms of a, uh, which in terms of a
Hollywood movie, is basically free.
That is very very low-budget
There are, you know, a lot of indie films made with higher budgets.
So it was made for nine million dollars.
This one was probably made for substantially more,
and one hundred and ten percent of that increase was
Bruce Willis and Samuel Jackson's salary.
-Of course.
-Like, that is...
So if this one was made for even a hair over 30 million,
I would be shocked and I would easily say that...
25 of those were in just those two salaries.
-So almost the entire budget of the movie was simply
paying for those two actors...
-Just paying those two actors.
...and there was no budget left over
for pretty much anything else.
-Yeah, so...
So Split, one of the things that I became aware of about halfway through, it's like,
"Oh, this is a bottle movie."
And so when I looked up the budget and it was only nine million,
I wasn't surprised, because it's, like,
80% takes place in one location.
-Yes. I love, I love...
... bottle episodes, the notion of bottle episodes.
-Yeah.
So now we had a bottle movie.
-It's a bottle movie, you know...
Now, bottle movies are not intrinsically bad
10 Cloverfield Lane is a bottle, and it's fantastic.
-It was a fantastic, fantastic movie.
It makes great use of great use of that format.
The format is not intrinsically flawed, but, you know, you start to sense
when a movie has not really been
written with or around the constraints, but has been
is just trying to squeeze into.
And like tries, to tries to trick you in in subtle ways. And...
This is the most M. Night movie... ever?
-Oh. oh.
Everything, so, okay, everything that was insufferable
about the writing of Lady in the Water,
how like you had all of this...
"Meta" commentary on, like,
the nature of screenwriting and storytelling,
In just like the most head-up-ass way possible.
Yeah, that's all back.
Except now, it's not just there.
Now, it's also peppered liberally with comic-book vocabulary,
So, it's already head-up-ass,
and it's also just like, unbearably cringe-worthy.
All right, audio died.
In 2000, uh...
Comic book movies were not marketable.
So it was you know, kind of this stealth,
this stealth comic book movie, but really it was a family drama
Centered around a very kind of grounded sense of superheroes.
It's like, what if superhero mythology is basically just a...
Oh, and this got...
Tip.
What if a superhero mythology is basically just
a light exaggeration of, of actual things.
And so David Dunn's powers in Unbreakable are,
Are very nebulous and very constrained.
-He is very... he is resilient.
-He's resilient, he's strong...
That's...
Kinda it.
And there's this whole, you know,
There's explicitly a scene where his son like pulls a gun on him
and it's all the tension is about, like,
Can he actually take a bullet?
-His son is convinced that dad's the next Superman.
He just wants to prove it to his dad
by pulling a gun on him, and they have to talk him down.
-Yeah, and it's it's tense because we don't know,
David doesn't know, nobody knows!
And it's like...
Not gonna find out. 'Cause if you find out the hard way,
It's... what if it's not?
And...
One of the things that goes through that
is that, you know,
David's "weakness",
quote, air quote.
-Air quote.
-Air quote "weakness", is...
That he can drown.
-Mm-hm.
And, so, this is again kind of that, like, you know,
Exaggeration element. It's like Superman has kryptonite
and it's like, well, David's...
weakness is that he's normal.
-Yeah.
In regards to, he must breathe air
And is thus capable of drowning.
Water doesn't, like...
take away his powers.
It's just terrifying, because...
-He's the same as anyone else.
So you go from being invulnerable to being vulnerable,
and by and large the movie works because
it's a lot of metaphor.
It's leaning very heavily into the fact that,
into this whole idea of,
Superpowers as, themselves, metaphors. So...
David is unbreakable. He is physically unyielding,
but he's also emotionally unyielding, which means that
he's unable to open up to his family,
He's unable to be emotionally vulnerable,
and that causes him tons of problems in in his life.
And so, you know,
The unbreakable man needs to learn to be vulnerable.
I guess his other power is that he can, like, sense evil?
And again, ... it's psychic powers, but it's like heightened intuition.
-He was already working security, basically,
so it was a skill he already possessed,
taken to an exaggerated form.
-Yeah, then it's like he can already read a crowd and
Identify who is looking to cause mischief
and it's like, okay. All right.
*sigh* Oh, God...
So, Glass! *laughs*
Okay, now that we've established the baseline...
-And at the end of Unbreakable, the twist reveal was that
Samuel L. Jackson's character had been deliberately sabotaging trains,
Waiting for the miracle survivor, to prove his theory.
-He had been manufacturing mass casualty events.
-Okay.
-So there was a...
There's like three that are referenced?
So, like, a hotel fire, and an...
Airliner accident? And then the train crash...
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm hazy on the second one.
I remember the hotel fire, and I remember the train wreck.
-That was sort of the end of the movie reveal and we reveal, that, you know,
He had been killing mass numbers of people looking for his chosen one.
-Yeah, looking for his opposite,
and the thing about that reveal is that it's like...
Samuel L. Jackson isn't a super villain.
He's just a dude...
who has convinced himself that he's Ozymandias
because he's read "Watchmen" ten too many times.
-Yeah, that he knows "how it actually works."
He knows "the real way of things."
But he's really just, he's just a very unfortunate man
who has taken his pain in extremely unhealthy directions.
So...
So that leads to this movie, where he is in fact actually
super coordinator mastermind.
-Oh, that's unfortunate.
So, one of the big...
one of the big twists,
That I didn't even really realize was going to be a twist
because I had already pieced it together watching Split,
is that...
Kevin, who is James McAvoy's character,
a.k.a. "The Horde",
and they use their character names a lot.
-That's unfortunate.
And in fact because they say "The Beast" so often,
I kept having flashbacks to other comic book...
adjacent property inFAMOUS,
where the villain of inFAMOUS 2 is The Beast,
and the Beast is headed for, uh...
fake New Orleans, to just smash it.
-Just have a crossover with all comic book characters
named The Beast.
-Yeah.
-Just have Disney's Beast show up, too!
Have them all show up.
-Just a field of Beasts!
They say that, they say that, but
James McAvoy's character, his whole thing, is that
he has dissociative identity disorder.
-Okay?
-And they say it out loud, like, it's not...
they say disassociative identity disorder a lot in both movies.
He has dissociative identity disorder
because his mother with, ah...
OCD, whipped him with a coat hanger as a kid,
so he was in an abusive household.
So child abuse gave him dissociative identity disorder,
which then gave him superpowers.
-Oh dear...
-Because he only has superpowers when the Beast is in control.
So the entire premise of Split...
-Okay?
-is that there's this doctor, trying to prove that
some people with dissociative identity disorder,
it's not just, like, fractured personalities,
It's not just protective layers of compartmentalization.
It is, in fact, distinct people,
and that the the different identities can in fact have, like, correlating physiological changes.
So like one of Kevin's identities has diabetes,
and others are like stronger or weaker,
and the Beast is, like, super jacked-up roid man cannibal.
-Cannibal?
-Oh, and he can climb walls.
-Okay childhood abuse... gave him superpowers.
-Gave him superpowers, but now...
His dad was trying to figure out how to help him
and get him away from his mother.
-Okay?
-Don't worry. There's, this gets even worse.
-I mean, if she was physically abusing him with a coat hanger regularly,
you don't think it'd be very difficult.
- It doesn't seem very difficult.
But, so, there's a scene where she and Kevin
dropped dad off at the train station.
And he gets on the same train that David was on, that Elijah sabotaged,
and they try to do this really clever cut where they go from the new footage
and like pan over into the footage from Unbreakable.
I probably would have been more impressed by it
if it wasn't clearly, um, cheap.
-Cheaply done?
It is rather old footage at this point to try and sew in.
-The transition is done. It's just it's so clearly like there's so many things that are done where it's like
oh, they've just reused footage because
You know
It would save the money it would cost them less to license the unbreakable footage from Buena Vista then it would cost
to like literally shoot another scene
Yeah, yeah so mr. Glass created the Beast by trapping Kevin with his abusive mother
Thus necessitating that Kevin developed the Beast for protection
So
But how did he know this kid had the potential to become a superhuman was he just doing this know so many?
Waiting to see if wonder cuts. Well, no, so it's just a byproduct
So this is supposed to be like oh like entwined destinies
That it's like, you know that that the beasts
destiny and
David's destiny are entwined because of these coincidences
It's it's fate
Okay, but it's also a
Work of fiction which it then constantly reminds you of because everybody is talking about you know
narrative devices all the way through it and and thus calls attention to its the fact that it is itself a
Contrivance and it's not very clever. We are like 1% through my notes
Okay
Okay, let's find alright so it's a very cheap movie it's a bottle movie they okay so after
after the the like initial setup
Which oh
It's giving me okay, so so David and his son
have in the span of time between unbreakable and and
glass
gone into
business as a
Father-son like home security outfit, but also a me
Scratching it paper, but also
parallel to that
Do like crime fighting on the side Blake not that his son had any
Superpowers. No, so his son is is
Like sit back at base on the radio, like listening to the police scanner and typing things on the computer. He's dispatched
He's dispatched. There's zero effort put in the the acting is atrocious
It's all very very very flat
but so that whole bit like so it's like he he figures out where James MacAvoy has a bunch of
a
Bunch of cheerleaders chained up in a brick factory. Oh
And there's a very short
Confrontation and then the next hour and a half actually
Really the next rest of the movie take place
At this hospital that they then get locked up and they basically get sent to Arkham
Where where Elijah has been kept for the last 19 years I was about to say where his
Yeah last time so of course, of course
Coincidentally, that's where they go
and so this doctor then gets introduced who's trying to like cure them of the
Delusion that they are superheroes or super-powered. Okay now
this ends up being very bizarre because her methods and her goals are for the most part like
Incomprehensible
okay, and
It requires that the movie
never behave even
remotely
Logically, like part of this is going to be the Bruce Willis
Didn't want to work and part of this is going to be like narrative convenience, but they can't they can't have
conversations with David
because one
David can just
He's he's otherwise a normal dude like he's not
He's he's doing vigilante work, but it's it's not like he's dressed up
He's not playing Watchmen
You know, he's not a caped hero
He's just, you know puts on a ski mask or whatever and
puts on a rain poncho and it's like
Oh the rain poncho becomes like his his symbol even though in unbreakable
It was just it was raining
Put on a poncho
Yeah, and so it becomes like it becomes like his official costume. It doesn't just become a car
I mean at the start it's like it's still kind of a thing of convenience
Like how do you want to kind of look innocuous? It's like you
Put on a poncho its Philadelphia it rains a lot
But so he doesn't have any sort of pretensions and could very easily
You know if they even tried to have a conversation like the natural
Written path of the conversation would be David just being like what am I doing here?
I'm just a dude who got I got caught in
I was like if the police want to charge him with criminal activity for his vigilantism
Sure, sure, but why is he like, you know like yeah, I you know, it's like do you believe you're a superhero? No, I
Know I I don't I don't
Yeah
But like he could just so easily
deny it and the other half of it is if he didn't want to deny it the fact that he's like super strong and
Ngayon vulnerable is like empiric. It's like demonstrable. You can just demonstrate that
And so they have so they avoid it they they get around it by just never going there but just ignoring him
Yeah, but this is the other thing. Okay, so they get them to the hospital. So it you find out that
okay, so there's they have a fight in the brick factory and they fall out of a window and then there's like all
These like cops lined up and a lady in a you know
white trench coat and they flash all of these lights and it causes the Beast to like go away because
Kevin's
Trick he's got two tricks. There's two tricks for dealing with Kevin one is saying his real name
Well, that's easy
Which only one person ever tries to actually do in this movie
Oh wait. No, they do it one other person does it but they
That ones handled very
And the other one is flashing a bunch of lights Adam in a pattern that forces another personality to
Take the light
Which is how they described the like who's in control of kevin time. Is this like who is standing in the light?
and so they flash these lights at him and that force is basically a personality swap, which so if you're fighting the beast
Well, you swap to a non super-powered personality and suddenly he's vulnerable and it's like, okay
But so they take them to not Arkham
Lock them up in in specialized cells just just like in
Batman
So Kevin's cell has a bunch of lights next to the door. So if he gets too close to the door it like flashes and
Forces of personality swap. Okay, which I guess I'm going to stop him from Beast moding
Kevin goes beast mode. He's a bad guy
Yes, because the Beast is a cannibal
Okay, but all most of his personalities are also bad guys
like one of them is has declared herself High Priestess of the Beast and
wants to like
purify
the world
With her beast person and with her beast she's gonna unleash the beast
Wait for it
So flashes lights and that's so it's can cancel beast mode with lights off
but then David's has all these like this like sprinkler system set up inside of it and I'm like
Sar, they gonna is that the plan like just drown him. Just just keep
Human environment but spritzing now and that's the thing. So like like with the misbehaving dogs
Yes
So he misbehaves once and this is what this goes back to so cheap is they don't show any of this
they don't turn it into an action sequence of even the
Loosest kind like he goes outside the building and you hear this like pump start like you're looking at this giant water
reservoir and this pump starts up and
You hear like sprinkler sounds in the soundtrack and then it cuts to the interior of the room
water like draining out through a grate in the floor and David like sitting up and like some water comes out of his mouth, but
then like
The room is otherwise dry
Like the bed is dry
he sits on the bed and you hear it make like a crinkle noises and
And it's like so they didn't fill the room to pacify him. They don't believe he's a superhero
Why do they have the sprinklers because all of a sudden water is just his kryptonite
but their whole thing, is that okay that the psychologist believes she can cure him of his supernatural abilities his
demonstratively true supernatural abilities through psychology
okay, so
Second third twist of the movie. Okay, is that she actually like this is very late in it and okay
We'll get okay, we'll get to that. What was the thing?
What was the previous thing that I said we needed to get to ok, the Beast, you know, what screw it
Let's just jump to the end
Okay, so a huge portion of this movie an hour of this movie is spent just like futzing around in
the hospital
For no purpose. It's a lot of very
cheaply shot
conversations
They tried to make an aesthetic out of not having reverse shots
So like an entire scene, like there's a lot of points of view. There's entire scenes that are shot just like
Looking at one character and everybody like everybody else's dialogue is off screen
It's persistent enough that it becomes aesthetic but one it's a bad aesthetic and two. It's obviously getting around a
very cramped
shooting schedule because
They couldn't keep paying for Sam and Bruce Bruce most of the movies. He does these days
he has a writer that he will only work one day and
Everything else is done through doubles. So so I think for this they probably got him for
five
Okay
He just did not want to be there no and clearly does not want to be there like does not care
he's happy he's he's not like
bored
But he is completely checked out
So a huge chunk of the middle and we're just gonna have to go past like all
Water system and David's cell just vaguely our were just screwing around in the hospital. How does the doctor?
Oh, the doctor just knows a whole like everything about David's past
Oh
there's
Jackson told her everything there's a scene. No because he's being kept in like a
like heavily sedated state
Why?
because he's now a super villain with like Master Mind powers and can like
break out of anything and hack any system and it's
It's not that he had done a bunch of research to figure out how to cause a train to break
It was that he like knew of these systems intimately. I
mean
It's really funny because in break in
unbreakable
There's a scene where he like overhears a bunch of people talking about the hotel and you know, basically saying sir
Oh, yeah, man, like that thing was built back
you know, it's like I was staying in there is it's wild it was built back in like
1860 like it's totally not up to code like there is not enough fire escapes and and like you could see this like oh
Okay
If I just start a fire in the hotel
People will die because it's a old
Hotel and isn't up to fire code and doesn't have a proper sprinkler system and there's no fire escapes
He did not like
manufacture a convoluted sequence of events that then caused a fire
He just went did some arson in an old building and people died. He was just an opportunist
yeah, and but now he like now he's like he
He disassembles a laser
And like steals like this optical device out of it in order to like trick
The people from thinking they were doing like this like laser lobotomy on him
Okay
Okay. All right. We were gonna talk about weird beast
We're gonna talk about the beast, but there's one other important scene in the hospital
which is when you find out that he's been faking because he's being like
he's been switching all of his pills with aspirin and
Using like sleight of hand whatever but so he goes and talks to Kevin and like I'd like to meet the beast
let's have you know blow whatever he's leaving and
Patricia who's the High Priestess person out Kevin's High Priestess personality is like and what per say what her chance is your
Name and he's like wheeling out of the door and he's like turns around
First name mister last name class
And it's like, okay
Okay one this line would be bad enough if he had just turned around and said you can call me. Mr
Glass or just said mr. Glass. Yes, first name mister last name glass
wheels away
Okay, couple scenes like short scenes, maybe three minutes later
Flashback to him say first name mister last name glass. They liked it. So good. They used twice
Alright, let's just jump to the end so there's a whole set up about how it's like it's like the tallest buildings in
in
Pennsylvania
And
Then it's like we're gonna go that like there it's being it's having its grand opening and so like the eyes of the whole world
are gonna be there and you'll go and so
His plan is that he's gonna free the Beast and force
David to then fight the Beast in front of the media so that the whole world will see that superheroes are real
He's waited many many years to set this up
Surely he could have created other
confrontations at an earlier point
Let's all right, let's put that aside let's just accept that. Okay, so they're gonna go fight
Like I said, this is a cheap movie
and now this is where it becomes the most Shyamalan movie is that you can total see minaj just sitting there thinking like
Hey
It's not us. Yeah, it's gonna save us money, but also
It's a subversion and a twist. They don't fight at the towers they fight in the parking lot of
the hospital
That we're already shooting at
okay, so
So it was a budget rate that's supposed to be a twist so the climax which goes on for a very long time
like about
25 minutes
Is in the parking lot in front of the building not in front of the big tall tower in front of the hospital
I'd ask why they decide to fight there, but I guess it really doesn't matter. It's and
and it's
so
Is he sad that they don't go all the way to the towers he picked out to fight like that
They decide to fight there to screw with him like fine
We'll do your show fight
But we'll just do it here cuz we are feeders or we don't feel like walking. So they've got this huge lead on David and
they get up to the parking lot and then they just like they just dick around like
tipping over security cars
Like the the Beast like
tips over a car and
Then grabs a couple nurses and throws them into the back of a van and then David comes out
He's like you stop right there and then they have their showdown
Okay, so the
Supernatural elements have been heightened from unbreakable. Okay, but they haven't been heightened that much
Everybody's pretending or everybody's talking as
though the Beast and David are
you know like
Superman and
Doomsday going a town on each other as we have seen in so many so many superhero blockbusters
Yeah
so the final the final final final twist is that the footage of this fight gets out and
Yeah. Oh wait. No, I need to back up one twist
So the doctor she actually like works for this nebulous organization that I'll have clover tattoos on their wrists
So the clover organization the clover organization has been protecting the world for 10,000 years from super-powered people
And so they just like they fight super-powered people and then they basically just like kill them
They've manufactured their deaths
and
Okay
But so she's also trying to prevent all of this from getting out and then the like final twist
Is that all the footage gets out because there's all these security cameras and mr
Glass hacked the security cameras and streamed it to an exterior server and it all gets out
But so this is where it just all culminates in being hilarious
because the fight between the beast and David
It's all
Security camera angles so it's wide angles high up looking down
So this is just too
jacked up dudes like
wrestling in a parking lot
It's
Like it's like, you know
He the Beast pics like lifts up a car and tips it over and it's like okay cool
I saw somebody do that on Spike TV last week. I
Can find
800 YouTube videos of dudes who are like today, I'm gonna tip a car
Huh? I'm gonna pull a
tractor-trailer, I'm gonna we've loaded up my Ford f-150 with 30 with 30 steel plates and I'm gonna
Pull it by my belt and it's like it's like, okay
Strong. Yeah, why would anyone believe this?
This footage is authentic
And this is the thing is so the movie already kind of like references this discontinuity in that like in the at
Convincing David this is like convincing him that he's not actually super-powered
there's the flashback to unbreakable where Bruce Willis actually has acting skills again and
He he's talking to
Jacob what Joseph he's talking to Joseph and
says, you know Joseph's like you're a superhero dad and and
David says it's like son
There's guys in every gym across this country who can lift that much
Like what I did is like it's impressive but it's not
Special like you know, let's keep this some perspective
so like they call attention to that and
So when if you've already got that line like rattling in the back of your brain, and you're watching the Beast to do
Crazy, unbelievable proof of superhuman strength by just like rolling a car over
He doesn't even do it. Like he doesn't even like pick up the nose and like flip it he like
Goes from the side like from like the driver's side door and it's like, okay, so you tipped it the easy way
Like you you tipped it the way that if I were to be like, okay
I bet if me and four friends got together. We could probably tip a sedan over
The where we would stand we it's like no, of course
We're not gonna do it from the nose where ken is going from the side
We're gonna do it the short way cuz that's where it's gonna pivot better. And so it's like and
Leading up to him tipping it like actually like he just like Ramsey with his shoulder a few times
and so you've just got these shots of like
superhuman strength, it's just
shirtless james mcavoy like body checking a car
And then like same thing with David like he punches this like panel van it's like it leaves dents and it's like
Okay, you dented a van by punching it like
Okay, it looks more like a bar fight this entire you unconvincing, but it leaks
so so
Joseph the girl from the girl from split and and Elijah's mom
Leaked this to the Internet and they're all sitting there in Penn Station like
When did the upload finish
Actual line when did the upload wet or when was it posted? When was it posted?
two hours ago and
I'm just sitting there like if they're posting this to YouTube like I really want this just to end with like them like sitting there
Looking at their stats pages and it's like seven hits no
It's like
It
But it goes instantly viral with people like watching these videos of like James McAvoy typical
Ike the news is now like talking about it and it's like
It's like none of this is remotely
Except she likes in like the the Chiron is like escaped mental patients
your psych mental patients escaped from like blah blah blah hospital and then it's like the footage of him tipping the car and
and it's like
Okay, I can see why that would maybe be on the news because like yeah mental patient gets that and tip and rolls over a
Rolls over a security car like yeah, that'll do some rounds on the news as they like. You won't believe what's happening in Philly, but
it's like
Yeah, it's like this peeks at like Florida man
And yet and yet the framing of it is that it's like this is going to restore
humanity's faith in the in the
unbelievable in the spectacular in the
Supernatural that like we've become so jaded
We're so Jay now
Bye-bye being sold products that we no longer believe in in real superheroes
Why
So on the cinematography side on the composition side
Student film they've managed to get a couple big-name actors
you know, like clearly like a lack of coverage that they've tried to work around as
aesthetic an excessive use of like gimmicky camera angles
Limited to like two locations
You know
It reminds me of all the student films that I did like you watch stuff from
Satan's like you can always tell when they shot in the classroom because it's like you see the scenes very clearly shot
So I didn't see these are clearly shot. It's like I know you say yeah
Center
Yeah
Oh
Man, okay
the first fight scene the Beast
This is terrifying unstoppable being like picks up a table and throws it and then David catches. It just like throws it back
And so this is like this is like so let's roll back Patricia's whole plan to like
purify the world
with the with this like people will see the beast and they will cower in fear and it's like
So he is super tough like he can take he can take a shot gun shot
How does he hold up to like a cop with a gun? Yes so he can he can take a blast from a shotgun
But he is otherwise like he can climb
Like he can climb vertical walls and climb on the ceiling
He can tap a cop car
Not not exactly the kind of thing
that's gonna gonna be like
You know kidnapped the Queen of England and hold her hostage. And that is the exchange rate so that the Bank of England will sets
Or bison dollars once I kidnapped that Queen
You know, it's not exactly
Global domination stuff, it's more
Roll a 7-eleven and get away with a couple hundred bucks
for the police eventually chase you down and SWAT takes you out like it's
And
these unlike you know, it's it's not like
It's not like they they're leaking this footage of people concerning, you know, fire or whatever
But even if they did that it's like okay. We're gonna leak it on YouTube
We're gonna put it on YouTube and it's like peels on you people at one anything if if they did see it
It just be like Oh rad another special effects channel cool. I love roosterteeth
Do you guys are you guys gonna do anything with rocketjump?
Do you know them you should do so you should do a crossover with rocket jump
Or even better hey I have that red giant plug in
Like
It is clear is clear that M night Shyamalan has never actually posted a YouTube video you
Know what I'm just gonna lightly glance across the scene. Where a
underage girl is encouraged to
That that she can tame the Beast with
pure physical affection
Will just lightly glance across that it's a scene that happens
There's a huge interrogation scene where she's got all three in the same room it's
really stupid most of this movie like it's a lot like
Split in the huge chunks of the movie are basically just James McAvoy Hamming for the camera and it's super impressive
Because he like switches characters and it's like yes
He's an actor and in fact this kind of character switching like rapid character switching
it's called a one-person play and it's really
Really really really really really really really really common as an acting exercise
His actual power he's just an actor his actual power. Yeah his actual power it's like okay James McAvoy
Has taken a couple theater classes
Rad he's pretty good at it, but it's like this is not you know
This is not Laurence Olivier stuff here, I'm sorry
Yeah, so I guess the one thing I left out of the climax the one thing I mentioned the clover thing but so
he's her name Claire the girl from split like
stalks the beast down and brings Kevin out and then
He gets shot by a sniper
And then that's the first you see of the clover tattoo is it's like Oh a camera like swings across and it's like snuck through
There it's like you see the clover tattoo on his thumb
and then they like drag David over to this water puddle and like drown him and
Then and then mr. Glass is like I was I was
Well, you say he was wrong or he was lying that it's like this wasn't this wasn't
this wasn't the climax of
a special edition
This was an origin story all along
I
Am only barely paraphrasing this
That sounds like the type of line you put in at the end to make it seem like it was all like super smart and
If you're confused, it's because you're not clever enough to get what's actually going on cuz we only had
15 shooting days only five of the Bruce was only gonna be around for five of those
There's there's a scene where Bruce Willis does crime and it's not even him. It's a stand-in. He wasn't even like their crime scene
There's a lot of there's actually there's less of that than you get in an actual like modern Bruce Willis film
But there's still a decent amount of it. This movie was awful
Why?
Why make it at all? I think that's about all I have to say about. I don't know
That's that's all I can think of right now. I'm sure there's more that will come to me, but that
That was that was glass
Hey Amy, come here. I need a closing shot
It's Amy. Don't go see glass